mmunity is now on networks and I'm just
looking and it's the number nine show on
Netflix today and TV which is amazing do
you think there's actually a chance that
a community movie could happen and if
they said yes would you and Anthony
you're willing to do it we'd certainly
be willing to do it I mean we love our
community family that cast we're all
still very close to all of them you know
it's certainly too scheduled dependent
for us but I believe there will be a
community movie especially now that it's
doing so well and streaming that
somebody like Netflix could step up and
make that movie a lot of people don't
realize that you actually you and
Anthony worked on a lot of episodes of
community if you don't mind what did you
as filmmakers learn while making
community that maybe you know helped you
as filmmakers as your career went up
well certainly if you look at the
trajectory of our career you'll see that
we've worked with in samba 'ls almost
exclusively throughout our career and
eccentric in some ensembles
we're with diverse characters from
welcome to Collinwood
through the Arrested Development and
onto community so certainly we learned
how to tell stories with many many
characters or ensemble amount of
characters in a compressed time frame
you know sometimes we have twenty thirty
speaking roles in an episode of
community that was twenty one twenty
minutes long so there's certainly a lot
of time spent and energy spent training
ourselves to do that doing it in a
credible way where the story and the
characters could still hold together
another thing I think that we learned
from working on community was just that
you know we were constantly exploring
and subverting genre on the show and
seemed every week we were changing up
our style and our tone the look and feel
of it the score the way the characters
behaved and so we were able to explore
genre on a very deep level and when
you're subvert ink on where you're
studying it to such an extent that
you're you're really understanding the
nuances of it and I think that was
you know that was critical and certainly
the paintball episodes were a huge part
of our Marvel career my last thing on
community I swear by feeling on a
community movie is that obviously this
doesn't have to be some 100 million
dollar movie you know do you feel like
you guys if if this thing were to
actually happen that it could be pulled
off like a reasonable budget and like do
you know what I mean there's no question
and I think I don't think you'd want to
see it with a you know a really big
budget I mean it's part of what is so
compelling about the show it's very
quaint and it's it's you know it's
Greendale as an underdog and you know
it's I don't I don't think that you'd
want to suddenly execute it with you
know crazy high production value and set
design and you know unless we were going
somewhere fantastical or you know doing
one of our genre exploration concepts
but but I yeah I think you'd easily pull
that movie off for a burger